I got some friends here okay from 30
Rock oh may I bring them in
[Music]
[Applause]
yes you're so texed right now
[Music]
[Applause]
goodness I love you you got was so heavy
that my I was like hold on my biceps are
shaking she was shaking out this is true
Texas girl though because this is a vat
of queso I love it Jenna made it Jenna
made it it's it's her own personal
recipe I don't want to reveal where you
can find it but if you get Vita and you
turn it over on the back y all
know that's Texas this is a single
serving in Texas it is yes it is yep you
could do it for a family of four if if
your kids don't eat very much well it's
great is you just reheat it keep it I'm
all about that yeah that's right me too
welcome welcome to 30 Rod it's gonna be
so we've been waiting for you you fit
here like a puzzle piece we're going to
be looking for you in the elevators and
everywhere I know and thank you for
being a part of the opening so fun it
was really
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home